there's kind of a huge terror on me
because I think everyone has a very
strong idea of what Prince Charming is
and I'm sure lots of people have a very
strong idea of what their Prince
Charming is but we've stayed away from
that and he's never actually referred to
his prince charming he's just referred
to as a prince so I kind of tried to get
rid of that element that comes with what
what came in the carton and just take
this crap for what it was and the Prince
for who he is and what very closely with
Ken leading up to starting filming on
who this young man was and what his
background was and and we've added then
things you know things that were in the
script to me focused on them as well and
in terms of building his background and
the and the original version in the in
the cartoon that doesn't he made em you
don't really know very much about the
prince until you actually see him
whereas in this version we learned that
he is he's been at war for five years
he's he's seen a few things he's lived a
very different life to what you would
consider just the the prince charming
version of the princes you can see in
all these these different type of Disney
films he's a much more intricate and
true and trusting character I think he
goes through a huge change from the star
from when he meets her and with what
happens with his father during the film
and how he learns to kind of be his own
man and and and to stand up for the
things he doesn't agree with and then
you have this amazing character of
Cinderella who is faced with such huge
challenges and how she deals with them
with humility and and kindness and
something I think's just amazing human
quality and think you take these two
characters and you take the best
qualities that are within them and over
the course of the film you see those
qualities be pushed and tested and
actually the the the connection they
have with each other even though they're
far apart brings those best qualities
out and brings them to the points that
they need to get to be together in order
to have that union that gives such
strength to what this love story is
about love and is about two people and
about what they would do for each other
and what factors change them and make
them into the people that they become at
the
I loved working with Ken I thought
working with Ken since the first
rehearsal I had with him when I realized
that this this wasn't going to be that
kind of straightforward telling of a
story that everyone knows that we were
all going to have to dive in and and
create characters from scratch they were
they were different and and never been
understood properly before and I've had
a really amazing time working with Ken
from the books that he gives me to read
from the questions he asks me about this
young prince things that I have not
thought about or things that surprised
me or or things that I can gush to him
about oh this is exactly how the Prince
fuels or it asked me something I got I
have no idea what the answer to that
question is I'll have to go in and think
of it that so Kent challenges me as an
actor every day and challenges the way
out I'll play a scene and we'll have
really great discussions about what's
going on and what people's motives are
and and also what kind of character the
Prince says that it's not as
straightforward as playing a scene with
what needs to happen but playing a scene
with this element of a character who's
who's very alien for me and Ken's been
great diving into and exploring that
with me the first time I walked into the
ballroom set was amazing you know a lot
of these movies they use CGI to make
these kind of magical worlds but with
Cinderella we'd actually built these
magical places this ballroom that was
the size of a football field filled with
hundreds of supporting actors and
amazing colorful costumes and these
chandeliers with real candles on them so
it really felt like a fairy tale come
alive I loved making this phones there's
this is never a day on set that we
didn't do something special and unique
and and magical but of course I loved
all my scenes with Cinderella which were
a joy but I particularly loved building
a relationship with the king played by
Derek Jacobi and we we managed to have
these wonderful scenes where you can see
a lighter funnier sight to the prince
and
the relationship that he's got with his
diet which i think is really peaceful
you